i
[Música]
tras el histórico veredicto del jurado
que declaró culpable al ex policía
derecho wing por los tres cargos en el
juicio por homicidio del afroamericano
georg floyd la familia de la víctima
aseguró que puede volver a respirar y el
presidente joe biden pidió que sea el
primer paso para la reforma policial
en chad hay incertidumbre sobre el
futuro del país tras la inesperada
muerte del presidente idriss deby en un
enfrentamiento con rebeldes el consejo
militar de transición anunció nuevos
comicios en un plazo de 18 meses pero
los ciudadanos de la capital abandonan
la ciudad al temer un brote de violencia
en nuestra serie de tomates que viaje a
las estrellas nos centramos en la
estación espacial internacional una
instalación que vuela sobre la tierra
desde hace 20 años y cuyos componentes
originales tienen una vida útil de tres
décadas está envejeciendo y no sabemos
qué traerá el mañana partición venta al
sector privado o destrucción total
gracias por continuar con nosotros en
france 24 soy valentina torres sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos damos inicio en
eeuu en una decisión histórica del
jurado en el caso por la muerte de georg
floyd declaró al ex policía directo bing
como culpable de todos los cargos los
familiares del fallecido aseguraron
sentirse aliviados después de casi un
año de sufrimiento
el presidente joe biden instó a que este
caso suponga el primer paso para una
reforma policial en el país un discurso
al que se sumaron varios representantes
afroamericanos del partido demócrata
además la alta comisionada para los
derechos humanos de la onu michelle
bachelet indicó que cualquier otro fallo
hubiese sido una denegación de justicia
rodrigo se da no nos da más detalles
hoy podemos volver a respirar así de
contundente fue la reacción de uno de
los hermanos de georges floyd tras
conocer el veredicto de culpabilidad
para derecho bin el ex policía que
asesinó a su hermano en mayo del año
pasado
estoy luchando por todos en este mundo
si recibo llamadas recibo mensajes gente
de brazil de ghana de alemania de todo
el mundo de londres de italia todos nos
dicen lo mismo no podremos respirar
hasta que tú puedas respirar hoy podemos
volver a respirar
y las reacciones a la sentencia llegaron
también desde las más altas esferas de
la política estadounidense empezando por
el presidente joe biden quien hizo un
llamado a que este caso suponga el
primer paso para un cambio en el país no
puedo respirar no puedo respirar
esas fueron las últimas palabras de
george floyd no podemos dejar morir esas
palabras con él debemos seguir
escuchando esas palabras no podemos y no
debemos apartarnos de esto
tenemos la oportunidad de empezar un
cambio en este país el cambio en el
sistema policial y judicial
estadounidense ha sido durante mucho
tiempo un clamor en las calles
abanderado por el movimiento black light
matter ahora lo es también en la arena
política desde la bancada demócrata en
la cámara de representantes fueron
varios los legisladores que quisieron
sumarse al llamado del presidente en
aguante pero seguiremos estando
resilientes como parte del esfuerzo para
aprobar una legislación de reforma
policial significativa y para
literalmente levantar el principio de
libertad y justicia para todos en eeuu
ahora habrá que esperar hasta un máximo
de ocho semanas para conocer las penas
de prisión que deberá cumplir jobing en
cualquier caso no superarían los 29 años
dado que no cuenta con antecedentes
penales
previamente conversamos con nuestro
enviado especial en la ciudad de
mineápolis anthony belchí quien nos
contó sobre los últimos detalles y
reacciones en el caso
así que está muy buenos dias valentina
pues lo cierto es que aquí el centro de
la ciudad de minneapolis fue un
auténtico clamor segundos después de que
se conociera ese resultado del veredicto
de los doce miembros del jurado de
mayoría blanca que culpaban a derecho
vienen de los tres cargos a los que se
enfrentaba lo hemos visto al presidente
de eeuu joe biden
decir que se siente reconfortado por
este veredicto pero dice que no es
suficiente para combatir lo que
considera que es el que es racismo
sistémico que hay en eeuu por eso se
compromete se comprometió a impulsar
reformas reales y también pidió un
cambio en la legislación que regula a la
policía en el país norteamericano
también habló recogió las palabras de la
hija de jon soy freudiana diciendo que
su padre había cambiado el mundo y él
dijo que eso era sólo el principio
también el ex presidente barack obama
también
y reconfortado con esa decisión del
jurado dijo que ellos habían hecho lo
correcto pero que la justicia de verdad
requiere cambios mucho más profundos es
la opinión que también compartían otras
personas que se congregaban aquí en los
exteriores del centro de gobernación
donde se llevó a cabo en estas tres
semanas el juicio a derecho bing y
también el gobernador de minnesota tim
world dijo que esto era sólo el
principio para ir adelante hacia un
cambio y hay indignación en la ciudad de
columbus en el estado de ohio donde un
adolescente afro falleció por disparos
de la policía poco antes de que se
dictara la sentencia en el caso de floyd
de acuerdo con las autoridades la joven
identificada como máquina bryant de 16
años amenazó a dos niñas con un cuchillo
por lo que los agentes respondieron a un
llamado de emergencia uno de los
oficiales le disparó a la joven en
cuatro ocasiones causándole la muerte
los hechos generaron protestas en
diferentes puntos del estado
[Música]
en otras noticias tras la inesperada
muerte del presidente de chad idriss
deby habitantes de yamena la capital del
país africano huyen hacia otros destinos
en medio de la incertidumbre por un
brote de violencia el consejo militar de
transición que tomó el poder dijo que
habría de nuevo elecciones en un plazo
de 18 meses eeuu se pronunció y pidió al
gobierno de chad una transición
consistente con la constitución del país
informe de andré amaya
los habitantes de la capital chadiana
abandonan la ciudad muchos están
preocupados por lo que pueda suceder en
el país luego de que el presidente
idriss deby fuera asesinado
inesperadamente
lo que esperamos es el momento de la
transición no queremos otro
representante militar en el poder
durante esta transición porque habrá
problemas nuevamente se necesita a un
civil
son muchos en chad los que no quieren al
nuevo consejo militar en el poder sin
embargo los representantes del ejército
aseguraron que no será para siempre
las fuerzas de defensa y de seguridad no
buscan tomar el poder
me gustaría asegurarle a la gente que
los miembros del consejo militar
devolverán el poder a un gobierno civil
a través de elecciones libres y
democráticas en un plazo de 18 meses
el hijo del mandatario fallecido mahamat
idriss deby dirigirá el consejo militar
de transición y no el presidente del
parlamento como dicta la constitución
ante el panorama que se avecina eeuu
anunció que su embajada en chad seguirá
elaborando pero permanece bajo el estado
de salida ordenada por las
preocupaciones de seguridad en el país
bowers lo que queremos ver es una
transición que sea consistente con la
constitución de chad las instituciones
de chat están consagradas en su carta
magna pero queremos que los elementos de
esa constitución estén protegidos en el
futuro ya sea que eso implique una
transición del poder mientras los países
de occidente perdieron a un importante
aliado en la lucha contra el yihadismo
al norte de áfrica las autoridades
chadianas decretaron un toque de queda
nocturno y el cierre de todas las
fronteras en su discurso sobre el estado
de la nación el presidente de rusia
vladimir putin advirtió a occidente que
lamentará cualquier provocación contra
los intereses nacionales y aseguró que
la respuesta será asimétrica rápida y
dura el mandatario instó a la ciudad
danny a vacunarse para conseguir la
inmunidad de rebaño en otoño
contra el sme sin la vacunación tiene
ahora un significado central me pido al
gobierno al ministro de sanidad ya los
jefes de las regiones que se ocupen de
estos temas a diario pues murió existió
y todo el mundo debe tener la
oportunidad de vacunarse ya que esto
permitirá desarrollar la llamada
inmunidad colectiva en otoño clic y
munitis en medio del aumento de la
atención entre rusia y ucrania el
presidente ucraniano volodymyr selenski
invitó a su homólogo ruso a reunirse con
él en el donbass para evitar una guerra
señor putin estoy dispuesto a ir más
lejos y lo invitó a reunirse en
cualquier lugar del donbass ucraniano
donde hay una guerra y gloria a ucrania
su hado cree
vamos a india donde la situación por el
kobe 19 cada vez es más crítica en las
últimas 24 horas se registró un nuevo
récord de muertes con 2 mil 23
fallecimientos al tiempo que se informó
de casi 300.000 nuevos contagios el país
vive el peor momento de la pandemia en
el estado de maharashtra el más golpeado
por el virus 22 pacientes murieron por
un corte en el suministro de oxígeno
entretanto la desesperación ha llevado a
familiares de los enfermos a robar
tanques de oxígeno en el estado de
madhya pradesh
algunas personas recogieron los tanques
del almacén y los dejaron junto a la
cama de sus pacientes
no es que haya escasez de oxígeno en el
hospital el suministro es continuo
estamos identificando a los involucrados
en el saqueo y entablaremos casos en su
contacto avanzamos con más noticias
vinculadas a la pandemia esta vez en
américa latina' argentina comenzó la
producción de la vacuna sputnik la
empresa farmacéutica laboratorios
richmond sacif produjo el primer lote de
ese fármaco ruso contra el joven 19 que
será enviado al centro gamma de ella
para que realice el control de calidad
se espera que la producción a gran
escala en el país comience en junio la
nación sudamericana es la primera de
américa latina' en producir la vacuna
rusa
hoy les presentamos el tercer episodio
de nuestra serie toma pesqué viaje a las
estrellas el capítulo nos lleva a ver
hacia el futuro la estación espacial
internacional ha estado volando sobre
nuestras cabezas durante más de 20 años
pero sus componentes originales tienen
una vida útil de tres décadas este
jueves toma pesqué parte hacia una
instalación en envejecimiento a la que
no es claro que le traerá el mañana
dividirla en partes venderla al sector
privado o desmantelarla
pese a los anuncios del final de su vida
útil la misión de la estación espacial
internacional ha sido extendida hasta
2030 fecha límite de certificación de
sus componentes más antiguos ella se
hartan si hay ciertos módulos que
quedarán obsoletos en 10 años entonces
la obsolescencia es técnica y hay
soluciones técnicas y surgió el
reemplazo de elementos o módulos
completos así que es una posibilidad y
allí podemos comenzar de nuevo durante
10 años
ahora la prioridad es mantener la
estación a flote y no es casualidad que
los astronautas pasen la mitad de su
tiempo a bordo preservando su hábitat y
ya comenzaron a aparecer fugas una de
ellas descubierta gracias a una bolsita
de té que fue sellada con cinta adhesiva
los críticos dicen que la estación
espacial internacional es demasiado cara
ya se han gastado unos 150.000 millones
de dólares dicen que es arcaica y que el
mensaje original de reconciliación entre
occidente y rusia perdió vigencia pero
deshacerse de ella no es tan fácil no se
sabe cómo hacerlo para desintegrar la la
atmósfera como la estación mir en el
pasado habría que desmantelar la en el
espacio y multiplicar los viajes de ida
y vuelta pero nadie tiene un presupuesto
u otras soluciones dividir la estación
en varias partes y reutilizar las o
venderlas al sector privado
sharp ambos la tuvo algunos módulos
podrían separarse y usarse nuevamente
para hacer una estación más pequeña así
que los estadounidenses están pensando
en impulsar el sector privado en ese
país para hacer quizás una dos o incluso
tres estaciones más pequeños
por el momento el camino elegido es la
continuidad los elementos al final de su
vida útil serán reemplazados a medida
que sea necesario y la base espacial
continuará sirviendo como laboratorio
para aprender todo lo que podamos sobre
la vida en gravedad cero y para
prepararnos para futuros viajes a marte
poco a poco se desmorona la denominada
superliga el torneo de fútbol anunciado
hace algunos días por 12 poderosos
equipos de europa como una nueva
competencia alterna a la uefa champions
league en las últimas horas del atlético
de madrid y el inter de milán se
retiraron luego de que los seis equipos
ingleses abandonaran el proyecto al
respecto el presidente de la juventus
andrea agnelli uno de los principales
impulsores aseguró que la superliga no
existe sin esos clubes una de las voces
más críticas contra la nueva competición
fue la de pep guardiola entrenador del
manchester city
y no es un deporte cuando la relación
entre esfuerzo éxito y recompensa no
existe subies no te sport sport no es un
deporte si no importa si pierdes es por
eso que lo he dicho varias veces quiero
que las mejores competiciones sean tan
fuertes como sea posible especialmente
la premier league zona es posible su
especialidad reilly este jueves 22 de
abril se conmemora el día internacional
de la tierra una fecha que busca crear
conciencia común frente a problemas como
la sobrepoblación y la contaminación del
medio ambiente entre otros este año la
conmemoración se centra en sensibilizar
a las personas sobre cómo la
restauración de ecosistemas ayudará a
reducir la pobreza combatir el cambio
climático y prevenir una extinción
masiva
con estas imágenes llegamos al final del
informativo pero regresamos en unos
momentos con más noticias
[Música]